hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner and today
we have the season 11 executions and I
got to get a few things out of the way
real quick first off you'll be seeing a
weird ass face type of piece of paper on
all the enemies do not worry that's just
for the week one of the developers Larry
has been working tirelessly throughout
the many years the foreigners been in
development and he's finally taking a
break so in the sense of him taking a
break they basically plaster a little
piece of paper that I think looks like
ken's a vase or maybe it's his face on
every one of the enemies so that's going
to be that way for about a week but that
will go away so that has nothing to do
with the executions but might I say this
is the best amount of executions we've
ever had everyone except probably
shinobi has an amazing execution
everything has to do with bombs has to
do with axes Shaolin didn't even touch
the guy did this [ __ ] is [ __ ] it you
got to see it so I'll be showing all
that stuff right now in this video and
as well I'll leave in the description
every time stamp for the character it'll
be in order I go from Knights the
Vikings the samurai to the Wulin
and in the description it will be the
name of the execution and what time it
appears in the video so if you just want
to see your character I totally
understand it'll be in the description
down below but I highly recommend you
watch all of them because they are
absolutely insane
but with that like TV if you do enjoy
guys subscribe if you're new and take
care guys we'll see in a couple hours
for the reveal stream
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]